[Music]
in february of 1942
mexican farmer dionisio pulido thought
he heard
thunder coming from his field however
the sound wasn't coming from the sky
the source was a large smoking crack
emitting gas
and ejecting rocks this fissure would
come to be known as the volcano
paracoutine
and over the next nine years its lava
and ash
would cover over 200 square kilometers
but where did this new volcano come from
and what
triggered its unpredictable eruption
the story of any volcano begins with
magma
often this molten rock forms in areas
where
ocean water is able to slip into the
earth's mantle
and lower the layer's melting point the
resulting magma
typically remains under the earth's
surface thanks to the delicate balance
of three geological factors
the first is lithostatic pressure this
is the weight of the earth's crust
pushing down on the magma below magma
pushes back
with the second factor magma static
pressure
the battle between these forces strains
the third factor
the rock strength of the earth's crust
usually the rock is strong enough and
heavy enough
to keep the magma in place but when this
equilibrium is thrown off
the consequences can be explosive
one of the most common causes of an
eruption is an
increase in magma static pressure magma
contains various elements and compounds
many of which are dissolved in the
molten rock
at high enough concentrations compounds
like water
or sulfur no longer dissolve and
instead form high pressure gas bubbles
when these bubbles reach the surface
they can burst
with the force of a gunshot and when
millions of bubbles explode
simultaneously the energy can send
plumes of
ash into the stratosphere but before
they
pop they act like bubbles of co2 in a
shaken soda
their presence lowers the magma's
density and
increases the buoyant force pushing
upward through the crust
many geologists believe this process was
behind the parachutin eruption
in mexico there are two known natural
causes for these buoyant bubbles
sometimes new magma from deeper
underground
brings additional gassy compounds into
the mix
but bubbles can also form when magma
begins to cool
in its molten state magma is a mixture
of dissolved gases
and melted minerals as the molten rock
hardens
some of those minerals solidify into
crystals
this process doesn't incorporate many of
the dissolved gases
resulting in a higher concentration of
the compounds
that form explosive bubbles
not all eruptions are due to rising
magma static pressure
sometimes the weight of the rock above
can become
dangerously low landslides can remove
massive quantities of rock from atop a
magma chamber
dropping the lithostatic pressure and
instantly
triggering an eruption this process is
known as
unloading and it's been responsible for
numerous eruptions
including the sudden explosion of mount
saint helens
in 1980 but unloading can also happen
over longer periods of time
due to erosion or melting glaciers in
fact
many geologists are worried that glacial
melt caused by climate change
could increase volcanic activity
finally eruptions can occur when the
rock layer is no longer strong enough to
hold back the magma below
acidic gases and heat escaping from
magma
can corrode rock through a process
called hydrothermal
alteration gradually turning hard stone
into soft clay the rock layer could also
be weakened by tectonic activity
earthquakes can create fissures allowing
magma to escape to the surface
and the earth's crust can be stretched
thin as continental plates
shift away from each other unfortunately
knowing what causes eruptions doesn't
make them easy to predict
while scientists can roughly determine
the strength and weight of the earth's
crust
the depth and heat of magma chambers
makes measuring
changes in magma static pressure very
difficult
but volcanologists are constantly
exploring new technology
to conquer this rocky terrain advances
in thermal imaging
have allowed scientists to detect
subterranean hot spots
spectrometers can analyze gases escaping
magma
and lasers can precisely track the
impact of rising magma
on a volcano's shape hopefully these
tools will help us better understand
these volatile vents
and their explosive eruptions
did you know that there's an even more
explosive and destructive kind of
volcano
known as a super volcano 650
000 years ago when the yellowstone super
volcano last exploded
it covered north america in nearly two
meters of ash
and rock find out more about these epic
eruptions
with this video